[Music]
yeah i'm definitely sweating under my
eyes which i don't think i felt
sweat there before so
i'm feeling it
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by dewalippa
she's a two-time grammy award-winning
singer-songwriter in her latest album
future nostalgia is breaking all
kinds of streaming records during
quarantine but today it's a simple date
with destiny against the wings of death
do aleppo welcome to the show
thank you so much for having me i know
that you're not much of a plan b
person what's going through your mind
right now before we dig in for lunch
here
just gotta go you just you go you do it
and you don't give up
[Music]
smells good can you see it
i guess it's not very much that it's
like the first one
it shouldn't really be
um
that one's really nice so future
nostalgia dropped at the end of march
right as the realities of the pandemic
were settling in
and the mechanics of a big international
pop album rollout are typically so
precise and tactical
looking back on what must have been a
difficult decision to just release the
album anyway
what's something you were super stressed
out about in the moment that totally
turned out to be not a big deal at all
would anyone care is this like a good
time to put it out
is there so much like suffering going on
in the world and
um is is the music what people need but
i also realized that
you know i wrote this album to get away
from any like outside pressures anything
that
was kind of going on in the world to
kind of put it behind us and just dance
and have fun and i was like maybe the
time is now maybe the time is to just
put it out and
and the response was great because it
could have gone one of
like one of two ways i feel and i'm i'm
really happy that people reacted to it
so well
so zesty i don't think it made it to the
final times profile she did on you but i
heard karen gantz say that when she
interviewed katy perry
katie named you as someone who has what
it takes to be a career artist
how do you think about your own personal
longevity like is that something you
even strategize
well i didn't know um she said that
that's really cool
and i'm such a fan of katie um
that's i i can tell you that story in a
second but um
in in terms of like a career artist like
my dream is to be able to do this for as
long as i can
all i want to do is like make music
write and perform
for as long as people will have me
really and back to katy perry when i was
like 15.
i i went to a katy perry show and she
was like inviting people up on stage to
go and dance with her and i was like i
have to do it
jumped up on stage danced with her made
my whole life
chipotle and habanero
[Music]
it's good it's a bit spicy
but not not too much
so someone who grew up a self-described
g-unit obsessive you may be interested
to know that our first ever guest on hot
ones was none other
than tony yayo legend
jiu-jitsu g you knit when 50 cent came
down to perform in kosovo
who was one of the first artists that i
ever saw perform live
i really thought tony ayo was for some
reason gonna come out of jail and show
up in kosovo
i was like this is this is the night
this is it's happening i know he's gonna
show up
fortunately he didn't 50 did an amazing
show
love 50. anyway yeah and on the topic of
that concert
my understanding is that 50 cent's 2007
concert in pristina's city stadium
was a historic event because it was the
first international artist to perform in
the capital as kosovo was declaring
independence
what do you remember about that time and
maybe even more specifically that
concert
um my god well it was like an it was an
open air um football stadium
it was freezing cold so everybody was in
there like winter clothes
i'd learned like all of 50 songs
i'd read the book i'd watch the movie i
was like super super ready for the show
really excited it lived up to all my
expectations i was like he's the best
i love him and that
thought has never changed since
harder than l my very own brand
guys in case you weren't aware this is
an anglophile show at heart so we can't
let you out of here without taking a
wing to talk about british things
for the uninitiated why is coco and
camden such an important london music
venue
i grew up in camden so um coco was like
my main
um constant venue that i would go to i'd
always check the website i would always
try and see who's coming down i saw
um j cole there i saw schoolboy q there
i saw bruno mars
and his like do up in hooligans um tour
and
it's like it's like a small venue it
doesn't have like a massive capacity so
to get to see those artists
in those rooms was so surreal and when i
performed at coco on my hotter than
heltor
it was just such a life-changing
experience for me not to be like the kid
at the barricade just like
screaming every word and and being so
like i i was so just passionate about
all the artists that i went to see and i
was so excited to be there and to be
on the other side was a massive dream
come true
[Music]
los calientes hmm
i have a little bit more
[Music]
i'm into that one so last year vogue
dubbed you the signature gen z
fashion star and i know clothes have
been a passion of yours since the days
of do a daily
a fashion blog you published in school
oh my god
don't um
how do you know about that you really
did your research didn't you
hey you're you're dualipa we have to
know oh my god
all right all right let's talk about it
my skeletons
well you know do i don't worry because
we're going to misdirect a little bit
what we want to do here is show you some
of our favorite duallipa fit picks that
we pulled off the wire
and i'm hoping that you can talk us
through each look to get the duallipa
style guide
directly from the source let's do it
i've noticed you'll sometimes use your
handbag as like a stylish paparazzi
evasion tactic
is that instinct or did someone teach
you that move okay so
this is definitely instinct because i
was going through a really
bad hair day on both of these pictures i
have bad hair days
quite a lot um so when i went
blonde um which now i've
this is actually the first bit of of
like promo that i'm doing
with with my hair back to normal but
when i went blonde
it was kind of dramatic because my hair
just slowly started like fizzling away
and i just got this involuntary fringe
yeah that was just like perhaps
literally outside the rehearsal studio
and outside
my apartment in new york and
it was more just self-protection
here you are in goosebumps sweatpants
and then an anime wrap puffer jacket
are those things you pick out because
you're interested in what they represent
or is it more just like hey that's a
cool looking jacket or those are cool
looking sweats
it's kind of like a bit of both like i
thought it was really cool i love
this this brand the jacket with like the
dragon ball z
like anime drawings on it from this
brand called scoot which is just a
really cool
brand and the designer she just a lot of
the the clothes she just kind of hand
paints and she
puts glue on them and colors it in and i
love the whole process behind
how she creates the clothes goosebumps
trackies goosebumps just one of my
favorite shows that i watched
while i was growing up i've always loved
scary things scary movies anything that
would get my adrenaline going when i was
younger and goosebumps would be
something that i
loved and i read the books when i was
little too
um and so that was kind of like a bit of
nostalgia
that i was like i have to have these
what's the backstory on the versace
bodysuit
[Music]
i remember i wore this for um promo that
i did for colbert but what was
quite funny was after i did the promo i
went to this restaurant
uh afterwards and i came out the
restaurant and there were a couple paps
and
you chose a really good picture because
there's one where bless the paphy was
like walking backwards didn't see the
bin bags which you see behind me here
and he just completely takes a tumble
backwards and i'm just there in the
pictures going
no then i was like okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna stop and
so he can take a picture because i felt
so bad that he he fell over
all right doolie but thank you so much
for the crash course are you ready to
move on here to the second half yeah
let's do it what's this one called
seafire gourmet reaper
hot sauce
[Music]
is this okay is this gonna set my ass on
fire
is it maybe probably
hmm
[Music]
yeah that's really good it reminds me of
this um
like albanian like
it's kind of like a sausage it's called
sujok
it's just this really spicy sausage
that's like grilled for ages and it's
it's got that kind of smoky flavor to
them did you grow up eating a lot of
spicy food because we've been doing this
remotely and
typically what i notice happens is
people just dump sauce on the wings like
kind of like how you are and we end up
with such big reaction episodes because
everyone's like
over saucing the wings but you're so
you're so composed you're so
yeah i'm quite i'm quite good with spice
i'm quite good
good at it my parents are really good
with spice like since i was a kid
i have like such an early memory of my
parents eating like really spicy peppers
windows open sweating almost crying but
literally not stopping and since i was a
kid
they're like try some have some come on
that's not so bad do it again come on
just keep going and i feel like
i've always been like really adventurous
and really into my spice and so i feel
like i've trained
my taste buds a little bit but i am
feeling it it's just not
crazy yet so i know you have a close
connection to your fans seeking artistic
feedback from a select few via group
chat and even talk about
bringing back old school write in letter
fan clubs
these stand groups particularly in pop
music seem to be so well organized and
tech savvy
is that kind of support empowering or
does it give you a little bit of an
uneasy feeling knowing that
even though they're acting on your
behalf you have absolutely zero control
over them
you know i i love social media i love
the whole um
connection with the fans and talking to
everyone and i spent so much time
just um like speaking to fans online and
you know having group chats with them
and going on instagram and creating
really like personal relationships and
but sometimes social media can be quite
intense
and when i was making future nostalgia i
had to
like take a step back from twitter some
of the negative stuff started really
getting to me and then i felt like if i
was to
make a record that i was really proud of
i had to take a step back from all that
and with the fan club i feel like people
have to really go through the extra
length to write me a hand
written like hate mail so i'm like if
that happens i'm like okay i'll read it
thank you i'll take the criticism but um
you know i think it it's it's nice to be
able to
kind of go back to basics a little bit
all right
starting to sweat from the forehead a
little bit which means i think that it's
uh it's time
for another one to number seven
okay i think it's this one right the
thor's
hammer super hot sauce all right
[Music]
oh no no no i [ __ ] this up i put so
much on
[Music]
figuring that one out yeah and like it
immediately made my nose start running
[Music]
okay so sniffles are here
your video for new rules has more than 2
billion views which is rarefied air for
any artist
besides just being a good record are
there specific details about that song
or video that you think helped propel it
to that level of success
i really think the music video was like
rocket fuel for the song there was this
one versace picture with naomi campbell
and kristen mcmenamy and it just came up
on my feed randomly and i was like oh my
god this is so cool it's like
two girls helping each other up you know
and i love that the imagery behind it i
thought the colors were really cool and
i kind of based the whole idea of what i
wanted the video to be around that
and how i am with my friends and i guess
that message
just translated so well through the
video and
that was really amazing that it did that
without us like
trying in a way what's your all-time
favorite dualipa music video
oh um you know
i really love um
i don't give a [ __ ] um
physical is my baby that took us a
really long time to
to do um then there's like electricity
and that was the first music video i
feel like where i was really
confident in myself and because i felt
so myself and so free
in that music video in that moment it
holds such like
importance and value and such amazing
memories for me and so
that too because i feel like if it
wasn't for that maybe there wouldn't be
like
that that feeling then i wouldn't have
had the confidence to go in and make
future nostalgia
beyond insanity
oh that sounds like thick
[Music]
harsh instant
oh yeah
this one like hits a little bit after i
feel like i'm sweating now
but like under my eyes well careful
around them don't touch them no no i'm
not going to
i was i was warned before i was like
that would be
such a mistake so my understanding is
that you went through a starving artist
phase while getting your start in london
living off supermarket meal deals when
the end of the month came around
do you have a cooking or grocery store
hack for the struggling musicians out
there living on a tight budget
beans on toast beans on toast that's
like
one of my favorite like english
meals no that's it's like i guess it's a
meal
am i crying i can't tell
i'm like i feel like i can feel tears
but i can't tell
yeah i feel like i feel like a sponge
that is uh slowly being squeezed
oh yeah this is like this is like the
silent killer i told you about earlier
it's like this is the one you can feel
anyway what's an albanian delicacy that
everyone should try before they die
oh is like
this roasted pepper like
like paste sauce it comes in a jar and
there's like
roasted peppers cooked for a really long
time with like a little bit of oil
salt but it's the spiciness of the
peppers that's
delicious and it goes on everything eggs
toast your like spinach pita
which is another one of my favorite like
albanian dishes it's like a
pastry with spinach and cheese which is
delicious
i feel like i want to blow it
oh my god
[Music]
okay this is uh this is spicy
if you could collaborate with any artist
from the disco era living or dead who
would it be
oh i was in the studio once with nile
rogers
and we were gonna we were gonna work
together on the record and
for some reason it didn't work for this
album but i'm dying to get back in the
studio with him if he'll have
me to like work on something together
from scratch
he's such an icon and such an incredible
artist it's still okay like it's spicy
but it's okay
i think i've like maybe i've like ruined
myself like i doused my pizza in like
scotch bonnet sauce until i'm like
crying but i still don't stop eating so
i'm
i've clearly messed myself up a little
bit but absolutely incredible
i like it i want one of these it's for
you take the whole table yes
thank you okay julie but
jesus one second
i might have a little bit more go ahead
as i really know maybe that's so arcy is
that just like oh look at me like
oh i can have this but i do kind of want
some but i just feel
i can okay the people will love it
indulge
okay i've got a big i've got a big wind
up for this one anyway
all right okay do aleppo we've reached
the conclusion of our spicy journey
together and i just have one more
challenge for you on the way out
i've read that besides singing one of
your lesser known talents is spelling
now whether or not that's true i have no
idea but that's not gonna stop us from
putting you on the spot anyway
this is our first ever hot ones spelling
bee
i'll give you the word i'll give you the
origin if you'd like for me to use it in
a sentence
i am happy to do that two out of three
and i think i speak on behalf of
everyone watching
we would all be blown away
first word is scoville noun of english
origin
a scale for expressing the relative
pungency of chili peppers against that
of pure capsation
okay scoville s-c-o-v-i-l-l-e
ding ding ding ding ding all right
xylophone noun of greek origin a musical
instrument consisting of a graduated
series of wooden bars
okay xylophone x
y l o p h
o n e bang bang two out of two
all right finally this is the last one
and it's actually the word that won the
1936 spelling bee
eczema eczema
e c z e m a
bang bang you've got all three right
i am humbled sitting across the zoom
call from you
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you my friend
this camera or possibly a second camera
if you've set it up
let the people know what you have going
on in your life hey guys
uh i just did hot ones it was very hot
um future nostalgia my album
is out now uh i hope you like it i hope
it makes you dance
send me videos of you dancing in the
kitchen because we know we love that
all right love you guys
let thank you this was so fun i've been
wanting to do this for so long
so i'm so happy to get to do this thank
you so much
born from a delicious accident the
classic garlic fresno edition came to be
when we accidentally took a batch of the
classic and mixed it
with 10 times the amount of garlic
recommended in the recipe
whoops well you know what at that point
a star was born
the classic garlic fresno edition is now
available
at heatness.com heatness.com to pick up
your bottle of the classic
garlic fresno edition around here
we call it the blue label